are you looking for the luxury watch
experience but can't commit to one
glamorous time piece of course this is a
good problem to have but in a world
where leasing or renting a private jet
and automobile even a house is possible
why not the same for a beautiful limited
edition watch well Randy brand founded a
private mentorship program for these
time challenged individuals here's why
the company is called 11
James I heard a story that stuck with me
at an net event years ago that they used
to present J bond with the 11 different
watches and gadgets they had made for
that film and bond was the prototypical
member and the notion notionally the
choice of 11 watches was what we were up
to and it just seemed to work so if
James Bond were around and who knows
maybe Daniel Craig will come knocking at
the door of 11 James we're open to that
call me Daniel there you go and what
kind of watch or what category I know
you got three different categories I
think you've got an afficionado a
virtuoso and a connoisseur so it's sort
of the gold uh I guess what the platinum
and the super Platinum exactly we have
three levels of watch as a huddle around
average retail price points of 102 and
$40,000 Fado connoisseur virtuoso okay
and those are the prices of the watch
those the average retail prices of the
watchet got it okay so you make two
choices as a member the types of watches
you want to wear and you also can have a
hybrid membership where you can wear
watches for multiple categories as well
as the frequency so our Baseline
standard membership is three watches
four months at a time so every four
months you give back your watch we give
you another one
uh if you want more variety you can do
six watches two months at a time or for
someone who has a bunch of watches at
home wants to dip their toe three
watches two months at a time where
basically every other month you'd go
back and forth from wearing your own to
wearing ours what's the most popular
watch model that people are looking at
at this point we have 30 plus Brands and
hundreds of models so it would be very
difficult to ping you know to say just
one all right well give us a c when
we're talking because I know that you've
got things like Rolex you've got
brightling Cartier IWC a whole bunch of
them those are all very popular
go ahead um it we our watches huddle
around four different pillars latest
greatest new models iconic Brands and
models Discovery as well as vintage SO
vintage Rolexes are incredibly hot right
now um virtually every brand so let's
say you want to sign up for a different
Rolex vintage Rolex watch from now for
the rest of the year what does something
like that run so at the effici level
which would typically be the price point
of most of those vintage Rolexes for 100
for $199 a month if you want to dip your
toe or $299 per month if you really want
it all in you could have a different
watch every four months do you get to
buy them I mean let's say you like it
and you you can buy it as well we do we
have a really robust Rewards program
where basically everything you do as a
member by being a good member turning
your watches on time renewing and every
time you refer a friend or a colleague
you're earning points very quickly those
points equate to additional watches
upgrades complimentary membership and
especially the ability to trade in
points for ownership so you'll call us
up you'll say hey I love this Rox
Daytona we'll say you have 85,000 points
keep it it's our pleasure what about
those apple watches right I mean I'm
sure you've been aware of uh the move uh
wearable technology any chances that's
going to be something that you guys
might think about well if you think
about our entry level collection
averaging around $10,000 retail we'd
have to come down before that would make
sense you know economically but we do
Envision having a collection that's
that's at a lower price point where the
Apple watch might make sense but like a
virtue phone for example exactly verto
foam would fit more than an $800 or so
Apple watch but I'm incredibly excited
about it one I love Apple product and
the gadgets and two there's a lot of
folks I know who got apathetic to watch
collecting and haven't worn a watch in a
little while and a lot of Millennials
grew up it's the first generation who
didn't tell time on their wrist they
tell time on their phone and now you're
going to get people back wearing things
on their wrist and a lot of people are
going to be like wow I kind of like this
but I don't want to wear the attack
thing everyone else is wearing and 11
James allows me that variety